thank you for joining us America Sarah's
with us in Branson Missouri hi Sarah how
are you thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I feel like my budget is
suffering because of this one piece of
puzzle that I can't figure out how do
you manage join me and lope system if
you can everything online like
everything's auto pay and you do a lot
of online shopping and you don't you
don't carry cash on you you don't go to
a grocery store I do I pay my debit card
okay that's not online okay so the way
the envelope system works is when you're
physically in a store you have an
envelope that is marked for a category
that has money in it that is in that
category from your budget for instance
food at the beginning of the month or at
the beginning of your pay period one of
the two you say in the grocery stores
we're going to spend 200 bucks in the
next two weeks on food 400 bucks and the
next two weeks on food and you put 400
ollars or whatever the number is in cash
in an envelope and when you go to the
grocery store you use the cash out of
the envelope to do the purchase not your
debit card that's how it works
same thing for clothing in the clothing
store same thing if you are buying
something online it's difficult to use
cash hello you're gonna use your debit
card there I'm talking about when you go
to a store but if you're gonna buy if
you put $500 in your clothing budget and
you spend $250 you spend $300 on the
line then you would only put $200 cash
in your clothing envelope to physically
go to the store with okay so you've just
got to decide the thing is when you are
out and about making purchases then you
will spend more if you are using your
debit card or a credit card
generally then if you use cash tons of
research says that so the number one
impulse location in the world is the
grocery store they are the best
merchandisers of all retailers they do
an excellent job shelf positioning color
coordination x' store design everything
is designed to cause you to walk past
more things than you have to in order to
have an opportunity to impulse people
impulse their butts off in grocery
stores okay it's it's it's designed for
that and so you spend more there if you
don't go in with a list if you go in
hungry and if you don't go in with cash
those are the three things that'll cause
it it'll help you with your grocery
spending but if you're buying something
online then you just reduce that
category so what you may want to do for
instance if you're buying clothing
online okay you may want to have an
online clothing budget and a separate in
store clothing budget two different
categories online and in-store the
in-store goes in cash in an envelope
the online does the other now you need
to realize too that when you're
purchasing online for instance an Amazon
Prime people impulse their butts off
there too because they don't even think
about what they're buying they just
click here and it's delivered to your
door in a few hours
right and that's called in the internet
world that's called friction the harder
it is to purchase something if a website
makes it difficult for you to purchase
something that's higher friction and
their sales go down and your impulses on
prime is one of the lowest friction
purchase points out there so people
spend their brains out on Amazon Prime
and they don't know what they don't cuz
they don't watch what they're doing
because it's very very very easy to
purchase stuff quickly and easily and
very convenient it's a nice feature but
it causes you to spend more you have to
be very very careful because their job
is to get your money and they're better
at their job than you are at yours you
suggest that at the end of week
I take out so much cash and then leave
whatever I know I'm going to spend
online and he's in the bank accounts I
do it that way
divide it yeah that's what I just said
yeah you need a separate category in
your budget for online purchases that
stays in your account and the other
category is your in-store purchases
comes out of your account in cash and
into an envelope marked for that
category for instance clothing or
grocery store or entertainment week
Sharon only carries about three
categories now in envelopes I think
we've got four categories and envelopes
total we've got she does clothing and
entertainment and grocery stores these
days that's the only three we personally
use and then I have one called Jim which
is gas entertainment miscellaneous GE M
and that's in my front pocket
that's my envelope it's my wallet and so
it's taking care of odds and ends that
I'm gonna do but it's a you know it's
got my redneck emergency fund which is
three $100 bills
and in addition to that my own
miscellaneous spending which 90% of my
Jim goes to tipping these days when I'm
going somewhere because I'm I love the
tip and so valets are working hard in
the Sun in the rain right people waiting
a table are working hard and so I that's
one of my favorite things to do now so
you just you decide how you're gonna
spend it but just keep in mind if you
can set systems in place like the
envelope system that cause you to handle
cash you're much more aware when you're
spending it creates emotional friction
is what it's called it makes you have an
ouchy moment when you're spending and if
you have an ouchy moment you spend less
when you lay a hundred-dollar bill on
the table and uncle Benjamin Franklin is
crying as he looks at you because he's
leaving because you're putting him out
for adoption with someone else
you realize you spent money when you
hand the plastic to to them they hand it
back to you you ever thought of that
when you hand money out it doesn't come
back when you hand plastic out it comes
back
so it's interesting you you hand money
you trade that piece of paper for an
item when you hand plastic you give them
the plastic they give you the plastic
back and the item there was no trade
there's no visual trade see what's not
activating in their psychology if you
traded you know if you're a kid and you
traded a toy with another kid we're
gonna trade you you you give them a
two-way they give you a toy there's a
trade there's a transaction going on and
that's what happens with physical paper
money there's a transaction you're
handing them money they keep it they
hand you the item of the service and you
get to keep that there was a trade but
when you hand them plastic they give you
the plastic back I understand that
they're supposed to you don't want them
to keep your card I got that okay but
you need to realize what's happening
psychologically there was no trade there
was no transaction it's like you left
with everything you got to keep your
plastic and you took their stuff wow
what a great trade is to see how that it
works emotionally it changes everything
so and it's really really bad online and
stuff like Apple pay and PayPal man when
you can just not even see a piece of
plastic now you just pull out your phone
and wave your phone around and half of
Home Depot lands on your pickup truck
good lord you know that's a problem
you got tools you don't even know what
they do but you got them baby you know I
mean you can impulse your butt off in
there and you know I'm not against Home
Depot I like Home Depot I shop there but
the point is you you really can create a
mess in these situations so really good
question Sarah and that's why we still
see you something as primitive as the
envelope system for a few categories and
it's all categories that happen when
you're not at home you're out in a store
you're on vacation take your vacation
envelope and you can break your vacation
up into restaurant spending you have the
kids a certain amount to spend in the
theme park right how many pairs of ears
can you buy you know but how many if you
don't have a lot of money so there you
go it's
it's a thing so you just again a
transaction needs to occur you need to
realize the easier it is to purchase the
less steps there are the less you feel
it emotionally the more you're gonna
spend we all do that anytime someone
says oh we're a cashless property just
use your room key yeah it's because you
spin more that's why they do that on a
cruise ship and so on think about it
this is the Dave Ramsey show